nintendo bethesda Ubisoft EA take to an
Activision on today's show and all of
the sort of things we think are going to
be talked about and then some rumor
control actually before we jump in
tonight we've had a couple of rumors
already today get leaked or just up here
on the internet and I guess the big one
is the the watchdogs to thing IGN front
page takeover of their site neogaf
spotted it I mean if the internet were a
ship it would be just at the bottom of
the ocean at this point because it
sprung so many leagues and you know I'm
in watch dogs too after initially being
like being revealed okay yeah so so what
sucks who's coming guys it's okay and
now here's the release date and asset in
San Francisco and here are some other
details rupes we had that marketing
thing go out yeah early what was the did
you spot the release date to remember
what it is November subset I'll took it
on a second and then the other thing is
well african-american protagonist and
then set in San Francisco it looks like
as well golden gate bridge in the
background so that sounds cool right
sure let's pop you how do you have the
goofy face like like any movie like it
wouldn't be San Francisco without the
Golden Gate Bridge even though I think
I've crossed it maybe twice yeah I
entire like that yeah not often do we
need to just hang it in Sausalito and
but yeah yeah kind of a good fit
considering you know this is the tech
hope of the world right like if in watch
dogs you know no no offense to Chicago
for maybe works a little bit better here
yeah I think but how are they gonna
utilize that right it's like dressing or
more I think they're gonna go to Google
they're gonna go to Facebook it's just
gonna have this whole coalescence of
technology in the Bay Area you're all
gonna real estate market you can stay at
I mean if they're if they're able to
like jump into the whole like you know
social strata and gentrification and all
that sort of stuff then like that'll be
pretty cool I guess we'll find out
pretty soon another one that leaked then
I guess pretty recently was it injustice
to there's some sort of screenshot i
think i could write a Batman facing off
against the flash and we've heard
Inklings of this for a while it's not a
surprising thing the injustice comic
series has only recently come to an end
but right it's something that's kind of
ripe for the next iteration in that
cycle hmm the date for watchdogs to is
November 15 to the ball which
on a Tuesday so yeah there you go
Tuesday Tuesday Tuesday maybe three days
later for Europe okay let's jump into
one of the many sections that we have
outlined today first of all gentlemen
Microsoft let's talk about Microsoft
they always do their press conference
it's like first thing on the Monday
right from and in the morning there's an
additional time yeah so we have a bunch
of software stuff first of all though
let's talk about the hardware project
helix Peter what is this bunch of
different consoles yeah what do we think
we're going to see you d three so if i
remember correctly it's two consoles one
that should be coming out sooner which
is sorta like a lightweight version of
the xbox one like a mini or something
yeah and then a more powerful version in
2017 that's the rumor right Scorpio is
what they're calling that one yeah so
Brandi they should keep like you
shouldn't just call it X Corps PL badass
I mean I hope that because we've got a
bet on that if it's called the xbox two
I have to shave my head right if any
iteration is called the xbox to any
iteration ever okay no and within the
xbox one's life cycle okay but if it's
not I mean if they if they shave your
beard that was the agreed upon me okay I
mean that's why we did not agree upon
that oh nice to know we can do that
right now it'll mark if that happens on
the mark the second time I've shaved my
beard presumably will be on camera for
game for game spot for gamespot yeah
yeah you did for extra life last year
two years ago I think of us yeah yeah
you baby-faced assassin yeah so Xbox
Scorpio the one looks like a sizable
increase in power over the original xbox
and our sorry over the xbox one now I'm
doing it and then there also a sort of
rumors of an xbox one like streaming
stick set-top box kind of let me tell
you what I think that is right that is
probably a way to let you because
Microsoft is always talking about
bringing xbox one and pc market's
together yes and let's be frank they're
not going to really do that
wholeheartedly but a stick that allows
you to stream from your PC to your TV
branding at the xbox is a really good
way to kind of attached that brand to pc
gaming and a soft move yeah so sounded
like a chromecast kind of thing you
could imagine yeah yeah I mean that was
the whole point of the Xbox in the first
place right now Microsoft wanted to get
inside of the living room and we've
talked before about steam boxes and that
sort of weird battle that's happening
about PC trying to get in the room in
that room I mean Microsoft already owned
the pc market essentially gaming market
and then they already are in living
rooms so kind of makes a good fit right
maybe they can attack it from that side
and especially because you don't need
things like the the connect to do this
voice-activated connectivity that's
something that's just built into Windows
10 you have Cortana and just bringing
that to two more technologies you
definitely be able to do that with a
streaming box and have that same
functionality do you get with Kinect
yeah interesting I mean I feel like
we've seen these things pop up in
various different iterations for the
past couple years would it be weird that
Microsoft might be the one to pull it
off or do you think they're a good fit
mm-hmm they're a good fit to experiment
in that space because I think they need
to differentiate themselves right now
and I think if you ask most people in a
battle between Microsoft and Sony in the
traditional consoles that they have
currently available Sony's kind of on
top yeah both in sales numbers and i
think you mean if you look at the track
record of games over the past year or
two yeah he's probably tracking higher
than them so if they were able to do
this move I think that would be the
smart way for them to say hey we're
different we're not just another one of
these trying to compute but they have to
announce a more powerful console as well
because if yeah if they're going up
against playstation 4 headlines will
just be dominated with here's the PS 4.5
more powerful bigger stronger and here's
the Xbox less powerful kind of streaming
thing like they need that mindshare up
and we also have our bigger beefier guy
that you're gonna write but they also
need to talk about these things because
all of the discussions that are
happening all the hype around this like
the expectations yeah if this is all
wrong and they they actually didn't have
plans to talk about it and I don't say a
peep mm-hmm the Internet's gonna be
really upset yeah and Microsoft are very
very gun shy about making a bad
impression at e3 because they've
basically spent two or three years
trying to fix that in the audience stage
yeah it's gonna be very very interesting
I mean an opportunity for them to flip
the script completely if they come out
with Scorpio and it ends up being much
more powerful than a 4.5 like that would
really make things interesting and let's
talk about software though consoles are
nothing without the games are going to
play it on them and some of Microsoft's
I guess staples are reappearing this
year at first of all gears of war for
we're hopefully going to see more of
that do you guys impressed by the demo
but all that they showed last year I
remember thinking it was really dark and
I wasn't really into it at all it's hard
to tell what was going on I I think
remastered was well-received it's nice
to go back to that world I'm interested
to see what they'll do with gears of war
for now like bringing that that series
forward it but it's also interesting
because we didn't get a Gears of War
remastered for two or three we just like
that first one yeah so
like I'm not totally sure how they're
gonna slot that into the overall story
is that something that people even care
about gears of war will it be like doom
doom I think was kind of a surprise
hidden out of nowhere that was just like
this role gameplay that's super fun
maybe Gears of War could latch onto that
same kind of feeling and it would be
really cool I'm a little bit reticent to
start and I guess criticizing or
worrying about games because of their
multiplayer beta is because doom was an
exact example of how wrong my
expectations were coming out of that and
did i do either of you guys play the
beta for gears of war multiplayer though
Gears of War for multiplayer but I
played a little bit of admit in a way it
felt like exactly like gears of war
multiplayer has always been and in a
sort of a frustrating way or like an
uninspiring way and so I guess I hope
that's not the case for the
single-player campaign and moving on
crackdown 3 Peter I want to talk to you
about this a little bit because
crackdown 3 they showed off a demo of it
you know a couple years ago and they
sort of briefly showed this like Cloud
Connect cloud for I guess processing
physics processing aspect of the game
you've seen a lot more of that now right
so tell you were talking about it very
excitedly yeah I played a live demo at
Gamescom last year in Germany late
summer and it's essentially like okay
everyone is playing the cloud and in the
cloud we have multiple like Xbox
equivalents stacked together yeah and
using all that processing power the
entire environments were destructible
and it was just insane to see not only
that happen but how players playing on
different consoles could influence that
and I've never seen tech like that on a
console before and granted it wasn't
playing from the console but that was my
gateway to it yeah and so as far as you
concerned it was just running on your
machine and all these buildings were
falling down right that was like
realistically I'm not just falling down
but like different aspects of them are
shattering based on what you did to
cause that impact right and it was the
most impressive piece of technology I've
seen on a console ever that's incredible
so I mean yeah I mean it might depend on
your connection you know who knows yeah
my dependent a lot of factors but what I
saw was was great I bet Microsoft's
going to be very very careful in their
use of the c-word I know you know cloud
has kind of become this this sensitive
topic
it sort of harkens back to the magic air
as well which I figure out trying to get
away from yeah interesting though crack
that I mean crackdown one fantastic game
crack down to maybe a little bit too
quick off the heels to really get people
sort of excited about it but yeah I
think fans would be looking forward to a
new crackdown and again we've barely
seen much of a tall sea of thieves this
sort of it looks like an MMO style
pirate pirate thing any interest in not
at all just I mean we're probably gonna
save this here yeah we need to see more
of it and I was kind of taken with
assassins creed 4 black flag that that
right that was a game that surprised me
with how much I enjoyed that that whole
ocean warfare aspect of it like living
on the high seas and see if they even
seems like it could tap into that same
feeling of being a seaman out on the out
on the ocean we all have semen but it
yeah it would be a lot of fun I think it
has the potential seaman not with it
standing and I've also heard rumors of I
guess the Battletoads things would float
around for a little while yeah any
interest in that at all yeah I mean I
yeah if they can capture what those
games did so well which includes
bringing back david wise to do the
soundtrack right they could make
something really fun in their hands but
as what they did so well was make you
hate playing video games i'm gonna
destroy your controller Oh dry a little
bit in the corner those guys were so odd
and just out there and they didn't
really make much sense when you compared
it to like the rest of us like the stuff
around it and it's a good opportunity
for them to recapture that but as we're
seeing with like a lot of games that are
trying to recapture nostalgia there's a
right way and a wrong way to do it yeah
and it's it's a delicate balance yeah
for every ducktales there's a doom yes I
am speaking of controllers new xbox one
controller a lot of people saying that
now that the Elise has sort of gone out
there and sold and some of that tech
might be rolled back into a new Xbox
especially if there are new xbox
controller especially if they're going
to release a slim version right they
usually sort of update those sku's a
little bit I don't I actually don't put
a lot of faith into that particular
rumor really it seems like you do have
the the two different types of
controllers you have your standard
controller and you have this really nice
high-end one and I think they'll
continue keeping that separation I don't
know that the high-end controller is
necessarily sold that well it's at a
price point that's enough for me to even
yeah
it but it is a really cool controller
and I think those two ideas will stay
separate and one of the things that will
hopefully save people money perhaps over
time is the sort of increased support
for PC that we're sort of seeing on the
xbox one platform and perhaps they'll
dive into you know we're seeing a lot of
luck walls coming down in terms of
online connectivity between the pc and
console and other consoles as well and
and then i guess with something like
quantum break where that was original
xbox one exclusive and then it came a
day and date on pc is this something you
think we're gonna see more and more of
Peter they definitely said that they
will be putting every xbox one exclusive
on pc right now on so that's a thing
like yes we will see more of that and
just going back to what I was saying
earlier about the pc to you know a stick
streaming on your TV yeah I think that
would be I really do think that they're
going to do that if they don't that that
seems just like an obvious missed
opportunity to me yeah there was rumors
on the giant bombcast last week I think
of Halo 5s campaign being playable on PC
and that Microsoft were doing tests
internally up in Seattle because they
did raise forge mode on PC or something
but the actual campaign itself so that
would be interesting I wonder fail I
mean that's why we're not the best
example of the game they would want to
be pulling over onto pc but i just i
just love how like halo is like a thing
it's like oh and maybe we can get it on
pc who knows it's like why wouldn't you
just yeah that's a problem oh yeah do it
forced as well as another one we've seen
the sort of the pc snippet they're
putting together for 20 risin three a
lot of people saying that that's a dead
on this year that it might be set down
under and we don't have any of our
Australian colleagues in here to give us
the scoop on that but what do you think
about that one I mean forces seems to be
like an annual thing for Microsoft at
this stage yeah at this point and I
think it's a horizon year isn't it
that's yeah what about you have worth
it's like called like you can set your
calendar by call of duty so I seems like
a good guess I I it for me personally
not something that's the most exciting
both because it is annual and because
I'm not as big of a racing guy I know
you're super into f1 and all guessing
games but I yeah but even for me it sort
of it straddles that line of the siming
and the arcade in a way that I've played
a sort of enough of those games Andy
Bauman he used to work here was a
massive fan of the force arising games I
think he wanted to get forward to rise
into Game of the Year if you had a
somebody
so there is a market for this you know
people are really into it and you know
the Tuscan sort of the world affords
arising to really look great as well for
that console which is very important to
them and that's kind of all the
Microsoft rooms that I have here you
guys have anything else you're thinking
about or something that we saw leaked
today you don't know how much credence
to give it but images of a dead rising
for right yeah yeah it's like see that I
mean well it'll definitely be another
xbox one pc exclusive hmm I seems
believable totally I mean it's been if
there was a launch title dead rising 3
was and so I've had a lot of time to
make that engine better to make a better
experience because dead rising 3 wasn't
the system's oh no I wasn't super
excited about that one I actually went
back and played us when I got my wisdom
teeth taken a couple months ago and it's
so much better it but it was surprising
how it looks like an early console life
cycle game you know so you know and I
thought said you were sort of loading
the fact that there was all of these
zombies on screen and yes really when
you go back and play it you're like
whatever you know we've we now like
hitman is a game I was playing last
weekend that's got way better crowd
dynamics oh speaking of games making a
comeback what if we see a new sunset
overdrive I'm sorry my phone is ringing
oh great who's that yeah yeah he's got a
Microsoft insider yeah she showed up I
would love to see sunset overdrive
return Oh totally ya if ya if they now
sunset overdrive to that might be the
one game that i think would really get
people excited rather than like a Gears
of War for in another report zone and
like all these just okay yeah we've seen
that you know sunset overdrive is one of
those games were like when it goes on
sale for like 15 bucks you see people on
Twitter like I know you didn't play this
yes you have no reason not to play it at
this price I was one of those people and
played us for the first time again
during wisdom tooth time and was totally
shocked at her its best in class for
those types of games that type of like
infamous you know open-world jaunting
like crackdown style yeah absolutely at
the very least they should release it
for pc yeah like it's crazy that they
haven't done that already angry I'm cool
so that's all our Microsoft tournaments
if you have any of yourself or does
anything that you're particularly
interested in that
no comments below